foreign
charging Knights on his own you're gonna
die hello everyone my name is I teach
ancient history at the University of
Oxford and I'm back now to look at some
more scenes from movies and TV and
judging how real they are
this is 13 years after Saving Private
Ryan and we're still just like no that's
how you do an invasion this is a modern
landing craft that they've dressed up to
look vaguely medievalish this actually
happened in the sense that a French army
landed on English soil During the period
of the Barons Revolt but it wouldn't
have landed in these Landing crafts
which are specifically designed to
support a modern amphibious landing and
in fact historically this Landing was
unopposed
and if the enemy is landing on a beach
like this there's only one way up the
cliffs why would you go down there and
fight them you just block off that ramp
and watch them starve to death or go
home it's your choice really you don't
have to fight you don't run any risks
it's better for everybody
these archers have a completely
impossible range they're firing from the
cliff tops these are hundreds of meters
away and they're firing up into the air
as well to get maximum range which yes
it makes your arrows go further but it
also means that when they land they're
basically just falling they have no
Force so if you hold your Shield up
they're just gonna ping off your armor
or your Shields
now these guys again are doing
everything they can to lose this battle
you see a bunch of Horsemen charging
down at you and instead of bundling
together you form a sort of loose line
that the horses can actually get in
between you and you kneel down for no
apparent reason no this is where you
Clump together right you form Shields
you get as close together as you can you
stick your Spears out the horses can't
touch you they don't want to get in so
close to an object that they can't get
through so they're not going to charge
in and then you have the range Advantage
because you have a spear and the guy on
the horse seems to just have a hammer so
you're just gonna poke them I would give
it a three out of ten The Landing
crafter obviously wildly unhistorical
yeah
any movies always love to use fire right
that's going to be very spectacular but
obviously this would have been very
rarely used especially when you're
defending your own village you're not
going to set it on fire
defenses are often built to try and pin
the enemy in place you surround them
from the walls you can fire down at them
now this town obviously has no defenses
at all which makes it more difficult
locating the enemy pinning them in place
that's when they're at your mercy they
did sort of portray that pretty well
foreign
[Music]
with archers is usually quite effective
you try to hide these people and then
they pop out when the enemy's most sort
of blocked and confused and doesn't know
where they're going but we shouldn't
overestimate how lethal that would be
unless you have a lot of archers the
enemy is sort of soon going to be able
to regain enough organization to throw
their Shields up and then your arrows
are not going to be very effective
unless you have overwhelming numbers you
wouldn't necessarily try to defend a
village that had no fortifications but
if you had to yeah you'd get up on the
roof
yes
the idea that the Orcs can actually fire
back at them and kill some of them
that's very unrealistic because the
villagers are going to be completely in
the dark the light is down there where
the fire is as far as the Orcs can tell
the arrows are coming from the night you
do some of these things like funneling
the enemy trying to block their way
trying to hit them when they're confused
or when they're distracted we give this
maybe a four out of 10.
the really cool thing about this scene
is they have a ditch and you can see how
it works because they have to go into
the ditch to approach the wall and it
means that the wall is very high all of
a sudden you can see this ditch forming
a part of an integrated defensive system
[Applause]
oh my God
the fighting for the ladders and trying
to make your way onto the walls and all
of that broadly speaking is accurate
there would be a lot of engineering
there would be a lot of times in history
when Siege Warfare is a place where a
lot of technological innovation happens
in a very short time and you have famous
instances like when the Romans attacked
this Greek city of Syracuse in Sicily
Archimedes is one of the Defenders And
he supposedly came up with all these
different devices they were so sort of
new and Innovative and strange that the
Romans supposedly towards the end of
this Siege became so afraid of these
devices that if they just saw a bit of
rope dangling over the wall they would
run away because they were terrified
that Archimedes had some new devil Read
to throw at them so this idea of using
strange machines in the defense of a
city is historical it's just that these
particular things that they've come up
with here they literally don't do
anything that a throne Rock couldn't do
these bowls just make no sense well the
marble shoots and when you know where
the balls come out you just step aside
right if you get hit by these balls you
have no one to blame by yourself
it has some things right you got to give
points for a good ditch uh give it a 5
out of 10.
we were ordered by Pierce
which they've turned into the battle of
the mode for some inexplicable reason
you can see the city burning in the
background this was a complete English
Victory they just overcame a small
Garrison in this city and then murdered
everyone but there was no battle outside
the walls or anything like that
so they're trying to tempt the French
into attacking by killing hostages in
front of them now in the Hundred Years
War it was a fairly common thing for the
English to provoke the French Knights as
a way to win so several of their most
famous victories at krasi poetsier and
arguably ajinku the French Knights
charged when they shouldn't have and
this caused chaos they charge into
prepared positions they charge into
disadvantages to Reign all these kinds
of things so the English clearly thought
of this as a great way to win and I
think they were just trying to transpose
this into the story of the Seas of
limoge but it doesn't belong there
that one guy who just runs out like what
are you going to do like my guy don't
he's gonna go up against an enormous
Army of charging Knights on his own
you're gonna die
they're saying at the beginning we have
orders to defend this bridge
strategically senseless because you can
just afford the river so if they're
trying to stop the English advancing
across the river which is what I guess
you're doing when you're defending a
bridge the English can just walk across
they don't form a formation they don't
have Archer support they don't seem to
have any Cavalry nearby
they're all going to die I'm afraid
should we give it a two out of 10
because they got the date right
these are supposed to be these wolf skin
Warriors these oof head now sometimes
they're also called Berserkers the idea
that there are these wild Warriors who
work themselves up into a frenzy and
then go into battle basically naked with
a complete disregard for their own
safety but actually when you read the
sources about these Warriors they're
just ordinary soldiers in the sense of
their equipment they wear Shields
clothes armor and they go into battle
fighting as a unit that behaves as far
as we can tell normally it's just very
much later sources centuries after these
guys were around start embellishing this
story as far as we know that never
happened
the spear throwing is actually something
that's very realistic they would throw
their Spears in battle but then of
course they would fight in close combat
wearing armor helmets and swords and
shields for the most part
you can climb a basic fortification if
it's a simple Fort made of wood in
particular you can either throw a ladder
up against it or climb it even by hand I
mean this does sometimes happen if the
enemy is not very prepared for you you
might be able to sneak in that way but
if it's defended at all this is going to
go very badly
stupid
if these Defenders had any sense at all
they would be forming a formation in the
streets of this little town and these
Invaders would have to try and break
that formation which they don't seem
very well equipped to do they don't have
any armor they don't have shields left
they just have their little axes well in
close combat against this beer you're
going to be at a massive reach
disadvantage Viking raids were obviously
endemic in Europe in this period most of
the time Vikings would Target obviously
more vulnerable places it's just not a
very profitable Arrangement or
undertaking to try and attack a town
that's defended so you'd go after
isolated farmsteads monasteries perhaps
settlements that didn't have any kind of
wall or Palisade even so that you could
actually just walk in and take what you
wanted in terms of the actual fighting
that we're seeing this is three out of
ten
actually that marching scene has a very
nice depiction of the fact that marching
order would be relatively loose you
wouldn't March in very tight order
because you're just getting each other's
way when they would be marching there
might be as much as two meters between
each man so they're showing that really
well and this
is the Roman army amid our forests and
swamps it's always very tempting I think
for Movie Makers to have these battle
planners either sketch it out in the
sand or to have them pour over a battle
map and plan maps and the kind of
top-down visualization of the world that
we are used to just wasn't common back
then you would try and find a high point
to overlook the battlefield maybe so
that you would have the overview but
generally speaking you wouldn't rely on
this kind of abstract visualization to
understand the space what cut off the
head the tail won't notice
we hack it hack it bits fundamentally
you don't need to split up this Army
even further because they're strung out
along a narrow road they can't support
each other anyway the front of this
column is going to be miles away from
the back of it but you're already in a
position where you can essentially
attack them with impunity you don't have
to do anything to these poor trees
[Music]
this is the Battle of the turtleburg
forest so this is a real event in which
three Roman Legions were destroyed by an
alliance of Germanic tribes they were
essentially drawn into a forest where
they did not know the past they did not
know the way and then they were attacked
from all sides and so fighting them when
they don't expect you great tactic
foreign
ing so good luck with making a big fire
in the middle of this field there was a
huge downpour which distressed the
Romans because it made the ground all
slick and slippery it ruined their
visibility it soaked their equipment
they weren't able to operate well
because it was raining all the time
they're using it to try and split up
this formation but again there's no
point if you're coming at them from all
sides you're pushing them back into
their own formation and the closer they
get together the harder it will be for
them to maneuver to fight to get
organized that's how you beat them so
making big lines of fire in between to
separate them actually works against you
because then they have nowhere to go but
directly into you and they're going to
fight all the harder so this is actually
a terrible idea but obviously it looks
really good on screen so that's what
we're going with I think it deserves an
8 out of 10.
why not either let the archers handle it
or send out a formation of guys let him
try and break a shield wall on his own
with only a little sword like he's not
gonna have a good time
obviously every time he has to fight
someone he stops that's when he would
get shot and he has to do that several
times and then find cover which just
happens to be there he's immensely lucky
he's basically wearing sort of premium
grade plot armor also I'm begging Movie
Makers to please stop it with the orders
to The Archers
never happens the knock draw loose thing
it's not real don't let anyone convince
you otherwise
the crab feeders men the men in yellow
they actually have these swords and
bucklers which is a very particular
style of combat where they have these
curved swords and these very small
Shields usually they would have been
made of metal and you can actually use
them both to guard yourself and to
attack so they have a very particular
style of armor That You Don't See in
movies or TV series a lot
in terms of the fighting it's just chaos
everybody's just running around engaging
the enemy one at a time hacking at
anything they can see it's very exciting
to watch but this is not a basketball
this is just a big mess two out of ten
these kind of protective circular
formations are tested though you do get
Romans sometimes forming a circle but
having them be in a single line makes it
much too vulnerable if even one of these
men dies the entire circle collapses the
enemy will be inside and no one will
have any defense you have to make that
into a multi-rank formation otherwise
it's completely useless
foreign
they just throw themselves at these
Romans like a zombie horde or something
it's kind of sad to see this kind of
portrayal of Northwest European peoples
essentially there's this tendency to
turn actual well-equipped Fighters into
these wild shirtless barbarians because
all the way back to essentially Greek
and Roman times we have this stereotype
that the people from the north people
from the forests of Europe are these
sort of barely civilized wild men they
knew how to equip themselves and Wealthy
Warriors in all of these societies would
have been just as well equipped as the
Romans in this scene
so they are confusing two things they're
confusing chariots and science chariots
which are different kinds of weapons
essentially chariots were still in use
among the most wealthy sort of Warlords
in Britannia at this point but these
would be missile platforms so on those
chariots you would be firing arrows or
throwing javelins for instance you
wouldn't be engaging them in close
combat because that would be a terrible
waste of your poor ponies these men
would be heavily armored not like you're
seeing in this fragment they would be
carrying male shirts themselves they'd
be carrying helmets some centuries
before this there had been an attempt to
create this kind of armored battering
ram in the form of the Scythe Chariot so
you attach Scythe blades to the wheels
of these chariots in order to try and
send them at enemy formations to break
them up this is something that we first
see in the Persian Empire but it never
works very well it's very easy to kind
of either get out of the way or dispatch
the writers and then essentially nullify
this entire device four out of ten
Arrow Loops are a way to make sure that
you can project missiles from the wall
while you are undercover so enemies will
find it very difficult to fire into
those Loops that's why they always have
this sort of wedge shape they will let
you cover a wide range of territory
these guys have been here according to
the story for ten thousand years
defending this Gap I don't know what
they did like they built the most simple
wall they could for about a week and
then they I guess did crossword puzzles
this is incredibly primitive in terms of
what it's trying to achieve as a
defensive fortification it's just a
single wall there's nothing you can do
about them climbing up breaking in and
getting to where you are make sure the
walls have bastions so that you can
cover the foot of the wall so that you
can defend yourself against an enemy
that actually reaches you the actual
scene they show us is a one out of ten
absolutely worthless
always looking for the crossbow men and
they're never there there's like one guy
I think among the French outside the
walls who has a crossbow but these
should be quite prestigious Warriors the
French just answered to the Longbow is
to have these armored crossbow men show
up in battle they treasure them a lot
and they spend a lot of time training as
crossbowmen and some of the wealthiest
city dwellers would equip themselves
crossbowmen for these fights
you also have pavisas which are
basically great standing Shields that
are used as cover mostly for crossbow
mineral archers it's basically just a
door that you're carrying around that
you set down in front of you so that
arrows will get stuck in the board
basically so they're using those to try
and defend themselves but then they
stand way behind it which is great I
guess like why did you bother them
[Music]
no one's wearing helmets which is also
great you can always say like oh we want
to see the actress faces there are
arrows flying Everywhere You Wanna
protect your head
[Applause]
the gunpowder use is so strange it was
known in Europe at this time and again
we're talking about a Siege so maybe
they were incentivized to try and use
tricks guns aren't known yet in this
period the earliest gunpowder weapons
these cannon that shoot again the big
arrow-shaped projectiles occur several
decades later so I have no idea what
they're trying to do here but I guess
it's because well they had gunpowder so
let's use gunpowder because then we can
show big explosions in fire and we
always want that it has nothing to do
with history this kind of weapon isn't
real and in fact this fight didn't
happen two out of ten my favorite
depiction of Ancient Warfare in movies
is the scene of the battle of galgamela
in Alexander which is not a very good
movie but the bustle at least is
depicted in a way that makes sense so
you can see the formations behaving as
they should you can see each unit
equipped as it should be so that I feel
is a really faithful adaptation a way
that you can actually see what this
might have looked like thanks very much
for watching if you enjoyed this video
why not click on the one above